all right so Captain Marvel have you
seen it yet probably nah doesn't come
out for a few more weeks but that's for
the MCU Captain Marvel it is now out so
this is my Captain Marvel spoiler talk
and that's a solid spoiler warning if
you haven't seen Captain Marvel maybe
you shouldn't watch this unless you
don't give a [ __ ] in which case welcome
let's talk spoilers and as always this
isn't a play-by-play of the entire
movies just gonna talk about a few more
things that couldn't talk about in my
review because that spoiler free so the
movie starts out with the stealth
mission which the Kree are hunting these
Scrolls is group of civilians and
they're like are these scrolls we don't
know scrolls can shape-shift I just
wonder was like they're not hostile
they're just civilians looking to settle
down turns out they are scrawls and he
was right because the scrolls I guess
are good guys which I did like that flip
I like a story that takes alright these
are the good guys these are the bad guys
and you find out the bad guys are
actually good and these supposed good
guys are actually the superpower dicks I
like that it can show good and evil of
just perspectives and it can also show
histories written by the victors or at
the very least the powerful obviously
the Kree are more powerful than the
scrolls you have more technology at
their disposal at least they have a
planet but other than that flip the
movie didn't delve deeper into that all
you know is they don't like them they
don't like them and it turns out oh the
Veii that didn't like them they're
actually the bad guys and the them are
actually the persecuted Brides and now
we're on their side and Ben Mendelsohn's
good I didn't find out the history that
the Kree wrote about the scrolls I
didn't find out what the scrolls
supposedly had done that made them so
bad like the scrolls in the Kree they
hate each other why cuz though with the
flip of ben mendelsohn being good there
is then the other flip that Jude Law is
bad he was supposedly Marvel turns out
Marvel's Annette Bening wouldn't have
called that but okay you turned Marvel
into an old lady which comic book fans
have been griping about that kind of
stuff for years comic book movies or TV
shows there's always a super powerful
character they just toned down to this
just average person and generally people
are like what why that's not them I
don't know enough about Marvel to give a
[ __ ] okay net benning's Marvel and Jude
Law is a dick who found Carol Danvers
who soaked up a bunch of energy come to
think of it I don't know how she soaked
up all that energy what made her soak up
that energy didn't my recollection
doesn't actually tell why she soaks up
that energy but then I read Jude Law
gives her his Vulcan blood now she has
green blood she will be none the wiser
that she's a human being which when they
called her veers I was like Oh verse
veers verse Danvers okay so they're
gonna find half of her dog tag that's
what and all this technology
happened because the tesseract is in
play which is case in point of what
makes this movie float when it floats
when I saw the tesseract I was like oh
the tesseract cool oh you got me movie
that that worked because that nostalgia
hit me like oh [ __ ] the tesseract been
around since phase one I do have
questions and I feel like we're hitting
retcon territory because how story was
Howard Stark found the tesseract when he
was looking for Captain America doesn't
actually say when that happened or what
year that happened but apparently Howard
Stark got that thing gave it to Marvel
who's Annette Bening for some reason did
in which she made a Lightspeed Drive
piece of tech well they left that large
chunk of the story out when they were
telling the story in phase 1 not that it
doesn't fit but for it to fit people
just have to have forgotten about it
just didn't mention it which ok dressing
the fact that this movie is a feminist
movie like that's what brie Larson said
it was undeniably it is if anyone was
like that movie has a feminist agenda
I'd be like yeah because it totally does
you see it in the movie and you've heard
it from the people who made it but you
still have to make the movie good you
can't have bad out of place comedy in a
thinly written comedy and expect people
to say the movies good you can't have
choppy action sequences in a thinly
written action movie and expect the
audience to accept it as a good action
movie these things are flavors sprinkled
into movies but they don't make for good
movies that's the same with a message in
a movie having a movie with a message
and having a movie that flows are not
the same like she has this scene where
she's totally kicking ass while the song
just a girl by no Doubt's playing I get
what they were going for but it kind of
comes across as some 99-cent guardians
of the galaxy action paced kind of makes
you go okay you're not guardians of the
galaxy yeah I said in my spoiler free
review there was something that was dumb
and the dumb thing is absolutely a lot
of people called it in the comments
section how Nick Fury loses his eye come
on man what it was like a joke on the
internet when he was like Katie Katie
people are ill but you the cat scratches
his eye out her hurt everyone I can see
Bill didn't actually think that would
happen but it did pulls up the cat the
cat just scratches his eye out I was
like no it's not he didn't scratch his
eye out but not at the end he was like
looking at glass eyes and Coulson's like
you have a big decision to make so I
guess he lost his eye so in Captain
America the Winter Soldier when you said
last time I trusted somebody I lost an
eye what he meant was trust me I'm a
[ __ ] dog person that changes the
entire context I just I hate it and
nothing can undo it unless we find out
after Captain Marvel he didn't actually
lose his eye but Intel
then whenever he flips his eye patch up
in Captain America the Winter Soldier
and he's like you have to keep both eyes
open I'm just gonna be like man the cat
did that that's from a cat the other
thing people hated that I didn't even
notice well I noticed that he changes
the name from this forgotten initiative
to Avengers initiative after he sees his
picture of Carol Danvers in front of her
jet and I know that it was zooming into
it and then he was like huh he erases
the name for the initiative and it cuts
to black alright so something in there
said Avengers but I just didn't see it
till help me out was was it her plane I
don't know but something in that picture
made him change it to Avengers
initiative for me it's not dumber than
the cat scratching out the eye
inspiration for names that comes from
anywhere can be baffled at how people
come up with names and when you find out
you'll be like that's how you hmm
they're actually more than a few retcons
if not contradictions when you line this
movie up with pre-existing MCU lore like
this in Black Widow and the Avengers
tell Hawkeye this is God's and Loki and
magic and nothing we were ever prepared
for well I guess that makes Mick very
kind of a dick doesn't it he's known
about that kind of [ __ ] for a long time
now and he didn't know about Loki or the
demigod beings of Asgard but he
certainly did learn in the 90s that
there are super powerful beings out
there in the universe and if he got the
idea then to put together a team like
The Avengers because they might be
coming back then yeah I would imagine
part of the training would be like okay
there are extraterrestrials out there
they're really powerful this is part of
your training so whatever it they better
prepare them the Avengers well I was
Black Widow just completely in the dark
and the Avengers she's like we weren't
prepared for those we weren't trained
for this see the bad riding or Nick Fury
is just a really neglectful leader I'm
gonna go with that first one like in the
original Avengers that were all like why
are you using the tesseract to make WMDs
Nick Fury he points the authorities like
because I him we learned not only where
we're not alone but we're hopelessly
hilariously outgunned but that's not the
case he learned that in the 90 he
should've been like this before you were
in the game the Kree Scrolls a glowing
lady there's stuff you haven't seen
contradictions like that in a movie like
Captain Marvel makes it feel like this
movie was written and directed by people
who don't know the MCU so people have
also asked or at least they said they
wanted me to address in my spoiler free
review if there is something that leads
into endgame like do you need to watch
this movie in order to understand
endgame don't know I haven't seen
endgame I would say no unless the
scrolls come back for some odd reason
even then there is a post-credits scene
when looked a little pager nickfear
used to page Captain Marvel then he
disintegrated The Avengers have that and
looking at the death toll and earth rack
up and look holy [ __ ] I've had
nightmares better than this and they're
like oh the pagers stopped doing his
thing captain Marvel's like right there
and she was like where's fury but do you
need to watch it I feel like that scenes
going to be an end game anyway kind of
like I believe it was Ant Man the
post-credits scene in ant man's when
Bucky has his arm in the vise nuts in
civil war that was the post-credits
scene that ended up being in civil war
anyway next one's the cat vomits up the
tesseract okay and the credits to the
cat it's not actually a cat it's an
alien posing as a cat it has tentacles
that eat people and apparently the
tesseract but even all right listen
dress the cat I heard the cat was like
this scene stealer life a cat made the
movie watch the movie and I was like I
mean the cat was the cat maybe it's
because I am a dog person Vanessa's cats
haven't been here long enough so the cat
didn't steal the show I mean when he ate
a couple people I thought that was cool
there's not like I walked out of there
going the [ __ ] cat man there's not
like the cat talks not like the cat was
Frank the dog from men in black if the
cat stole the movie for you what does
that say about any other characters in
the movie in the end I will say I know
the plan I saw Kevin Feige this
interview where he was like Captain
Marvel is going to head up the Avengers
apparently after endgame that's the plan
I don't agree with that plan because
that that is cheap that just cheapens
everything if you want a strong woman to
head up the Avengers great have at it
Black Widow you should have gotten your
own movie before Captain Marvel but if
Captain Marvel swoops in wipes out
Thanos then runs The Avengers I don't
see how she deserves it I don't see how
she has earned that like it worked for
james t kirk to go from cadet to captain
because we all knew james t kirk was the
captain of the enterprise so it didn't
feel cheap it just felt like alright
that's the fastest way to do it if that
happens with Captain Marvel it'll feel
like measuring you work for a company
you have the main manager the boss and
the assistant managers then you know the
low-level employees let's say the main
manager goes away retires quits whatever
naturally the assistant managers would
be like are at which one of us steps up
because we've put in the time now
imagine this company hires one of the
low levels ride up to being the boss
after working there for about a month
yeah employees and managers would be
pretty pissed about it and I would
understand and that's what that would
feel like if Captain Marvel just swoops
in and runs the show so that's that
those are the spoilers the things I
couldn't talk about my spoiler free
review alright so Captain Marvel have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's your favorite strong female
character in a movie bring on the Ripley
and Sarah Connor comments below and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want
click right here to see more
[Music]